them
because sir Bob Neal has to speak in the
estimates day debate so we will take him
first and he will be referring uh to the
fact that the liaison committee itself
has launched an inquiry in to explore
Select Committee excrucially of
strategic thinking across government
with which I can assure you the Civil
Service and ministers already well
engaged and we look forward to that
being a positive inquiry
opening the bowling but maybe that's not
the appropriate
start for today but I wanted to refer to
the inquiry that liaison committee has
set up because we attempt our tool to
coordinate the activity of all the
select committees and the purpose of the
inquiry is to look at the way government
seeks to coordinate policy and decisions
and action across government departments
do you recognize that there is a problem
with the UK government activities being
very siled
well I mean I think that is historically
been a concern of government I mean I
saw that as Chancellor actually most uh
probably most acutely when I was doing
spending reviews where obviously
departments would focus on the things
that were most important to them
and some of those areas are required
departments to work together to put in
bids were probably less developed than
you might like actually the earlier has
been an obvious example of that so I
mean I certainly I can certainly see why
the perception is there and as I said
the development of that as Chancellor
okay can I draw the position of the
ministry of Justice to your attention as
an example of this as a department whose
funding is is not protecting at
International terms but which is
frequently under pressure because of
failures in other parts of the system
for example people end up in the justice
system because they've had chaotic
Lifestyles Founders have broken up
they've been failed by Social Services
they've been failed at school they've
been failed uh by a drug testing
programs what is the means by whereby
government can take into account that
the pressures that are placed upon that
Downstream Department which is the
recipient of the failures elsewhere is
there a mechanism to recognize that and
to join that policy across those areas
yes so actually when I was Chancellor we
established something called the shared
outcomes fund which funded departments
to do exactly this to work together
particularly where they could tackle
some of the problems that need upstream
or Downstream depending on your
perspective intervention uh as her early
years as one I've mentioned where
actually the the support and families
program what used to be called the
trouble families program is a good
example of that where work was done to
evaluate the benefit of that program on
outcomes in education or the criminal
justice system so that government
overall could understand the value of
that program it should just be a
something that mhclg or d-luck should be
concerned with because actually all
these departments were benefiting one
way or another from that program so
that's the type of thinking that I tried
to introduce as a Chancellor and I think
that program is a good example where
there was clear evidence that it was
having an impact beneficially on
criminal justice outcomes two quick
examples the home officers recruiting 20
000 extra police officers that's
government policy
what uh steps are being taken to
properly fund the ministry of justice
for the extra Court time that will be
taken up by hopefully those police
officers capturing more uh offenders and
potential prison time because at the
moment they are not covered to pick up
the costs for those extra police
officers doing their job so I mean
actually my recollection because I was
Chancellor at the time that the funding
for that was put in place was that the
downstream impact of the 20 000 police
officers were calculated
and funded as part of the original
settlement for all those departments to
deliver on the 20 000 police officers
commitment uh but as I was transfer at
the time and I distinctly remember those
conversations and that modeling
happening with particular focus on the
downstream cost because you're
absolutely right and can't just focus on
the cost of the police officers
obviously that has a knock-on impact
elsewhere but my my recollection is that
was funded as part of the settlement at
the time for the 20 000 police officers
uplift program to join or join up
matters at least within the criminal
justice World
um there was something called this
criminal justice board that was
established back in 2015. it hasn't
actually met since 2021 but it still
appears in existence on the government
website I've got an excellent law
Chancellor could you perhaps assist him
to get that criminal justice board up an
operating again because there's a real
concern of a lack of join up across this
sector so I'm very happy to make sure
that the join up is happening and
actually I for example I'm tackling uh
illegal migration that's something where
I regularly convene different
departments particularly home office and
Ministry of Justice because it requires
and indeed to actually Delux and others
because it requires across government
coordination to deliver on the
priorities and I'll happily look at
making sure that we are coordinated and
joined up I don't thought the exact
right structure is to do here but I very
much am sympathetic to the thrust of the
question it's a potential cost savings
if you can get it right and again which
is to the benefit of the individuals and
indeed the tax Affair where we can
realize those and the final point I was
going to raise to burn very quickly is
this you've recognize in the past prime
minister the importance of the
reputation of the English legal system
for the United Kingdom stand in the
world in October
England Wales will have its first woman
chief justice will you make a point of
making an early opportunity to meet with
Dan Sue Carr when she takes up her
appointment so you can learn from her
firsthand the real pressures that there
are on the courts because delays are two
years or so for a small business to have
a money claim that can make all the
difference to its survival heard in the
county courts for example are really not
acceptable offer would you agree yeah so
I've actually met already with the
previous law chief justice I think a
couple of different times since I've
been prime minister and I fully expect
that I will continue those meetings and
engagement with the new law chief
justice and we are focused very hard on
reducing the core backlog obviously more
funding has gone into it as the
committee will be aware but also we've
removed the limit on sitting days in the
Crown Court we've continued to use the I
believe 16 Nightingale in Nightingale
courtrooms and actually we raised
industry retirement age who judicial
office holders all of which are
initiatives that help expand judicial
capacity to help us get through the
backlogs but it remains a commitment and
a focus of ours but I look forward to
discussing that uh with the new Lord
Chief Justice in due course
thank you very much thank you support
we're now moving on to the all-important
subject of the Russian aggression in
Ukraine and other Associated security
issues with Alicia Cairns chair of the
Foreign Affairs committee thank you
thank you prime minister I fear that we
are on the cusp of the Gaza crisis of
2023. yesterday we took up uh presidency
of the U.N security Council how do you
hope that over this month we will use
that to shed a light on what is taking
place but also what outcomes will we
achieve during our presidency so what
we're referring in specifically to let's
see so the Gaza crisis so essentially
israel-palestine but also as president
of the U.N security Council the next
month what have you tasked foreign
office civil servants to achieve well I
think well there's a couple of different
things you know obviously with regard to
the current situation in Israel and and
around of course we support Israel's
right to self-defense and have condemned
the recent terrorist attacks we would
say that the protection of civilians
must be prioritized in any military
operation and would urge the IDF to
demonstrate restraint in its operation
and for all parties to avoid further
escalation in both the West Bank and
Gaza both now and in in the days ahead
um and also call on Israel to adhere to
principles of necessity and
proportionality when defending their
legitimate security interests that more
broadly with regard to the U.N security
Council and our actions there I I would
imagine that we will continue to focus
on highlighting what's happening in
Ukraine Russia's illegal Invasion I
think one thing that we have
helped I think their leading role in is
ensuring broad support of the UN
condemning Russian action over 140
different countries have signed the
resolutions that we have helped support
in the UN and that will continue I would
imagine to be a focus in the coming
weeks and months and I think recent
events in Russia highlight from others
the illegality of Russia's Invasion and
I think hopefully other countries are
recognizing that and will continue to
use the UN as a platform to highlight
that so just before we move on to
Ukraine in your discussions with
Netanyahu how clear were we that we
should not see an expansion of legal
settlements and will we see Israel
Palestine brought forward specifically
by the British government they know the
next month
so settlements are illegal under
international law and we've said that
they present an obstacle to peace and
threaten the physical viability of their
two-state solution that we've
consistently engaged with Israel and
obviously I met president Netanyahu a
little while ago and we've repeatedly
made clear to Israel that we opposed any
settlement expansion and we've asked the
Israeli government to Halt and reverse
its policy
and moving then to Ukraine there are
reports that had the Vilnius Summit uh I
guess a coalition of the Willing will
bring forward some sort of security uh
support package a security agreement for
Ukraine can you set out for me what your
vision would be for such a security
agreement for Ukraine
well not not wanting to preempt the
conversations that are obviously
happening in private what I have said is
that I think it would be beneficial for
Ukraine and for the conflict for there
to be a multilateral declaration of
support for Ukraine
into the long into the long term and
there are various different shapes and
forms that can take those conversations
are happening the purpose of that
declaration assuming it can be something
that gathers broad support is to
demonstrate
the support for Ukraine will be in place
for the long term I think that will send
a strong signal to Putin that his
efforts are are in vain and ultimately
he should recognize that we the
Coalition of the willing to who are
defending principles of territorial
Integrity in the U.N Charter are not
going to go away and will continue to
give Ukraine the support it needs and
the means to defend itself against
current and future aggression but those
conversations are are ongoing and then
what's your level of confidence at the
illness we will see a path to Nature
membership for Ukraine set out and
agreed again those uh those
conversations are ongoing as you'll know
NATO is a consensus organization and so
we're having those conversations with
our partners you know what's very clear
I've said previously in the past that
crimes rightful places in NATO but the
alliance works by consensus so we will
have to work together with our allies
but there are things that we are already
doing that will help Ukraine on that
Journey notably the increasing the
interoperability of capabilities the
training of Ukrainian troops to Nato
standards
and the provision of NATO stand
equipment all of all our examples of
that type of support that will help
Ukraine not just now but on that longer
term Journey as well thank
you things urge the Balkans there has
been an international failure of
deterrence when it comes to Western
Balkans I think that's the best thing to
provide by the EU and U.S response and
recent punishments of Kosovo in the face
of Serb antagonism and Donald
secessionist rhetorics in Bosnian
Herzegovina as prime minister will you
now commit that we will rejoin u4 which
I'd add that both turkey and Chile are
members of and we also consider lobbying
for an expansion of k4's mandate in
Kosovo so that they can deal with the
illegal arms they brought across from
Serbia into Kosovo and which are are
being illegal Belgrade funded and Arden
militias in Kosovo
the first thing to say is we in the
government fully support Bosnia and
herzkabrina's territorial integrity and
sovereignty
will continue to take measures against
those who threaten that we're
particularly concerned I'm particularly
concerned about the situation in the
north of Kosovo which you'll be familiar
with and very much condemned the
unprovoked attacks by bribe protesters
on K4 Personnel the foreign secretary
has already told the prime ministers
that Kosovo and Serbia that that leaders
in Belgrade and Pristina do have a
responsibility to reduce tension and
prevent further violence our viewers we
must find a way back to the EU
facilitated dialogue with regard to you
for we do see you four as eu4 is vital
for peace and Security in Bosnia and
Herzegovina and our non-participation in
it doesn't reflect the importance of the
operation to the peace and stability of
the region and we're going to continue
to explore opportunities to widen
operation with the mission thank you I
would urge the government to look very
close that and then they're finally very
briefly just taking back to Israel
Palestine so yes or no answer would you
now put in place special Envoy for the
Middle East peace process to make sure
we have the adequate attention on what's
going on there I I think look it's
something that I yeah I know like the
scdo are talking to the honorable lady
about and happy to continue talking with
her about we continue to say that's
something that will be open to at a time
that we think it will be beneficial to
the peace process so it's not that we're
against it in principle it's just
figuring out when it can I'm going to
take that as a yes but something
future Prime Minister I'm not using my
time uh in this session for the benefit
of others but two supplementaries very
briefly
we're confronting Russian aggression in
Ukraine very vociferously and very
clearly how competent are you that
the International Community is not
appeasing proxy Russian aggression in
the Balkans
I don't I don't believe I don't believe
that we are and as I heard from my
answers to the um to Alicia we're
continuing to take quite a robust dance
against proxy it's not just in that
region but you know previously in in
Africa as well with Wagner because you
know where we see threats to territorial
integrity and sovereignty I think it's
important that we do our best to stand
up for them and that that's what we do
and the war in Ukraine will last as long
as uh the friends of democracy around
the world allow it to last the more
support we can give the quicker it will
end successfully for the ukrainians
are we doing enough and what more could
we be doing
well we've I think as everybody knows uh
provided 2.3 or providing 2.3 billion
pounds in Military Support for Ukraine
this year matching what we've given last
year which uh I believe puts us second
only to the Americans but I think it's
more as well as just the Quantum of
support it's a type of support where we
have been consistently out in front in
the type of capability that we are
providing to the ukrainians and training
them on that you saw that with main
battle tanks which I was the first need
to announce we would provide and
actually provide and then most recently
with Storm Shadow long range weapons
which are having a beneficial impact on
their current
uh on the current uh state of the
conflict and we will continue to do that
with them for opportunities to provide
ukrainians with the support they need
the priority remains as it always has
been you know heavy armor artillery
long-range weapons and training most
recently combat air where we will play
our part as part of an International
Coalition to provide
combat capabilities particularly
training of pilots and we're starting
that this summer in fact which is
something that I know the ukrainians
have warmly welcomed and we continue to
talk to other countries about increasing
their support for Ukraine both in
Quantum and in capability and I think
that is important at this stage because
the priority is to ensure that the
counter-offensive can be as successful
as we would all like it to be thank you
prime minister Greg Clarke on science
and technology and AI uh thank you sir
good afternoon prime minister I promise
a few days ago you told London Tech week
that the possibilities of AI are
extraordinary what do you see as the
biggest positive impact of artificial
intelligence
well I think just in the last few weeks
in the news reporting you know you've
seen some of the promise of AI paralyzed
people being able to walk the the
kind of cracking of the structure of
almost every known protein and you know
starting to better model reactions in
nuclear fusion so it just gives you a
sense of the variety and that is there
and also when you combine that with a
computational power of quantum I think
you can really start to imagine a future
in which of an incurable diseases like
cancer and Dementia or new ways to grow
crops all might be possible I look for
me I've kind of put it in a couple of
different categories I think
straightforwardly on the economy side
the interesting report from PWC recently
that estimated 10 GDP benefit over the
coming decade
um you're starting to see that in the
way that companies are using Ai and
indeed leading companies like palantir
opening that they European AI HQ here
and the quality of our research Etc so
that's on the economic side and I've
spoken in the past about AI holding out
the promise of being a general purpose
technology and the economic research is
it's very clear that that leads to a J
curve effect and productivity that we
are on the cusp of hopefully realizing
and then in public services I'd say
health and education are the two areas
where you know I'm excited particularly
in healthcare I think reasonably people
are reasonably familiar with the
opportunity to speed up diagnosis
of a range of different conditions but
also improve the productivity and
accuracy of for example people looking
for skin cancers is interesting dumb AI
technology that has been deployed or
robotic surgery and then in education
the opportunity to reduce workload for
teachers whether it's lesson planning or
marking but then also provide
personalized tuition for children the
Khan Academy is starting to roll out an
AI chat bot which has I think enormous
potential because we know that that more
personalized approach to learning which
has huge benefits for children
particularly disadvantaged children and
tutoring in the physical sense is hard
to scale but the technology allows us to
provide that and I think that would be
transformational absolutely so lots of
upsides but in that speech a lot of tech
week you said that we must do AI safely
so what you see is the biggest danger of
so I would categorize the risks into a
few different buckets I think
first you know it's the socioeconomic
risk from the large-scale societal shift
that the technology will bring and
that's often what technology does that
doesn't mean you should stand in the way
of it but it just means to make sure
that we're cognizant of it and provide
people with the skills they need to
flourish in a world that is being
changed by technology I think the second
is the risk of misuse and that is
whether it's open source models or
otherwise you know the ability that they
well they can be used as tools to
generate this information or identify
and exploit cyber vulnerabilities or
create harmful content or deep fakes or
child sexual abuse that's a kind of
second category I think the third
question would be tool use whereby
Foundation models that can be used to
activate capabilities in the real world
and then the last category is what
people would describe as capability
overhangs and that kind of Trends into
the area of more existential risk
because there's just a you know a lack
of understanding at this point about
what the potential of these models might
be now now obviously separate to all of
that the National Security risk which
I'm sure Donald acknowledge I appreciate
and limiting what I can say but I think
thinking about it in those four
categories is probably the right way to
to go about it thank you and you've
convened an international safety Summit
uh for the Autumn are you intending that
to be a summit of like-minded countries
like the US and Japan perhaps or is it
for all countries a bit like the
international atomic energy Authority
that includes countries like China and
Russia which what do you have in mind I
think look I think in the first instance
a mainly what we're trying to do is
acknowledge that there is a global
Dimension to this Challenge and AI
doesn't respect National borders
countries
are at varying stages of their thinking
about how we can put guard rails in
place to make sure that we can realize
the benefits of AI in a way that's safe
and secure and it seems a sensible and
reasonable step to just try and bring
some of those countries together to talk
about these problems you know in a
collective Forum because ultimately
there will need to be some coordination
so I think it's quite early thinking as
I said it's more just about bringing
people together who are countries shoot
together well it's just bringing people
together who are thinking about these
things in a in a similar way to exchange
ideas share information and as I said
because AI doesn't respect National
borders and I think we will all benefit
from hearing and talking to each other
in a conversation with the businesses
themselves and I think that that is
really what this is about I think we're
a lot we're a long way from anyone
establishing a
AIA IAA equivalent for AI those things
are you know along into the distance but
in the first instance just talking
through this with like-minded countries
so you've got the summit you published a
white paper in March
um the the last session of this
Parliament begins in November will there
be do you expect there to be a an AI
bill in The King's Speech
uh I you know I'm not going to comment
now on Fourth session legislation all
those conversations are are happening
and no final decisions of being made I I
think actually
what we need to do and I think probably
we can do lots of this without
legislation
is sitting down and figuring out what
are the safety features in guardrails
that we'd like to put in place and I
think we have a sense of what some of
those might be whether it's
watermarking whether it's pre-release
information sharing whether it's
reporting a licensing of large training
runs
um whether it's pre-training or
pre-deployment disclosure transparency
on the data sets that are used I think
that's the kind of category of things
that we need to do to spend time on
which is why the foundation model task
force has been set up and funded
specifically in its early phase to focus
on Safety Research I think it's an area
where the UK can lead because we already
have good capability in it so if we can
develop that capability further because
it's a growing field it will it will
mean that we will know what to do and it
may well be and actually so far the
conversations with the three leading
Foundation model companies have been
incredibly Cooperative but they're
calling for legislation uh actually well
I think what they want are for
governments to put in place the the uh
the guard rails and they're very open
about that and they're very I say thus
far they have been incredibly
constructive and open and transparent
with government and want to try and find
a solution together which I said it's
too early to prevent what all that might
look like but you can imagine a world
where at least the initial stage that
don't require legislation necessarily
but actually just require us to get in
there and do safety evaluation on the
models or have access to them and I'm I
said we've had announcements already
from some of those Foundation model
companies that they will provide that
access to the government to be able to
do that on a on a priority basis which
I'm grateful for and I think will help
us get this right thank you I'm sorry
we're dragging behind people are going
to have to be quicker and I'll have to
be stricter uh damn darling Johnson home
affairs
mister I know you're repealing the court
of appeals ruling on the Rwanda scheme
you've said this policy is an important
part of your plan to tackle illegal
migration and stop small boats so do you
have a plan for what you'll do if the
appeal fails
I I said our belief remains that the the
plan that we have is legal that's
compliant with all our obligations and
we'll be appealing it vigorously and you
know what if you look at the ruling what
you'll see is
the law Chief Justice in his opinion
agreed with the high court and with the
government that the safeguards the
reassurances that we have received from
Rwanda are sufficient there's a very
specific point of contention about the
onward relocation potentially of people
who we sent to Rwanda I said we believe
that the safeguards if we have our
sufficient so we'll continue to
confidently and vigorously pursue our
case so you're betting everything on the
Rwanda policy being upheld in the in the
Supreme Court well no it's not and
that's that's not a fair
characterization of what we're doing
it's a gamble isn't it not last year
around Indy this year I set out a range
of things that we're doing to tackle
this problem yes so for example can I
come on to that because I've got some
specific questions
well just oh it's because you asked the
question it could be a very substantive
additional piece is the New Deal that we
have with Albania yeah Albania again
respect prime minister I've got very
little time and I do want to get through
some important issues with you so if I
could just leave that I've got your you
made a statement that we're betting the
house on one thing I think it's
reasonable for me to say well let me
give you an example of something else
that is significant difference
with the greatest respect promise I've
got quite a few questions I want to
answer you're clear that you think
Rwanda is going to succeed in the
Supreme Court just on the small boats
issue
um I think it's six months today since
you made your five promises to the
British people including stopping the
small boats now win or lose in the court
of appeal in the Supreme Court right now
your plans around Rwanda are on hold so
does that mean your attempt to stop the
small boats that's on hold at the moment
no and a good example of why it's not on
hold is our deal with albinia Albania
accounting for a third of illegal
migrants that cross last year
we looked at and that is surprising
given that Albania is clearly a safe
country and it's an ally the European
nation and it's a signatory to many of
the same treaties that we are on these
issues which is why our new deal with
Albania and a revision in in how we
treat illegal migrants from Albania
means I know you're very keen to talk
about Albania but I'm very keen to
actually address the fact that in June
wow you asked for an example of being
committed to continuing to stop the
boats outside of the Rwanda policy this
is a very good example of something that
has that we've returned almost 2015
actually who came across last year none
of the returns actually relate to people
who traveled in small boats last year do
they because we work through the backlog
of people we've got but because of the
new deal we are now able to return
people to Albania and you can start to
see the early benefit of that deterrence
because
the most recent data that we had the
number of illegal migrants from Albania
had
largest number of people who crossed uh
the channel in small boats last year the
largest number in any of the records
that have been kept uh over the last
five years
3824 the majority Com or a large chunk
come from Afghanistan so what I'm just
trying to get to is with the rate of
progress that you're making at the
moment when do you think you'll be able
to fulfill your pledge to stop the small
boats I said obviously the court will
have to determine its own ruling and
that is outside of the government's
hands it's the court that determines the
timing of itself but in the meantime we
can get on with a range of other things
as I said
okay talk about the deal in Albania the
other thing one of the other things in
Albania quite a lot well I'd actually
move on to one of the other things we're
doing is tackling illegal illegal
working to show people that if they do
cover illegally they won't be able to
kind of spear into the black economy
okay so one of the things we've done is
increase the number of illegal working
raids by about 50 can I just ask you
some questions and again all of that
will contribute I believe to a deterrent
okay with a great respect prime minister
I want to ask you this the illegal
migration bill which was introduced
earlier this year since that in the bill
was introduced 8 128 people have crossed
the channel in small boats so if we
assume your Rwanda policy is upheld in
the in the Supreme Court uh rwandra said
they can take a capacity of 500 people
so that leaves
7628 who've come across since the bill
was introduced what do you intend will
happen to those people
I said I'm I'm not going to talk about a
private commercial contract that we have
but our Awana scheme as we have said
multiple times is uncapped okay so I
think this is what the London says well
the Rwanda scheme is uncapped and which
is why I believe it can act as a very
helpful deterrent when the scheme is up
and running can I move on to your other
promise which is around dealing with the
backlog and when you came last time you
said you were going to double the
workforce triple productivity and
re-engineer the system to deal with the
backlog the Legacy backlog yet the
National Audit office has found the home
office is not yet making enough
decisions to actually achieve your
target of clearing that part of the
backlog by December 23. so I just
wondered what's what's going wrong
because you were very chipper last time
about how you were going to deliver this
yes so I think when I made the
announcement the Legacy initial Asylum
backlog was around 92 000 when I gave
the update earlier this year that had
reduced by almost a fifth by about 17
thousand down to around 74
000 so that is the progress that has
already been made in reducing the Legacy
initial Asylum backlog and I said that
those numbers were when I last gave the
update but they were down by around a
fifth so you'll deliver by December
time's up sorry moving on to the cost of
building crisis uh Harriet Baldwin for
the treasury Commission thank you very
much
now prime minister
's Hall of inflation this year
and how is that going what probability
would you assign to you achieving that
by the end of the year well leave that
to the forecasters but we remain
committed to Bringing inflation down and
halfway is a step on it going back down
to the inflation Target which is
obviously even lower than that and now
it is clearly that inflation proving
um more persistent Than People
anticipated but that doesn't mean that
the
plans and the policy options that have
been deployed are the wrong ones indeed
they're the right ones and whether
that's monetary policy responsible
fiscal policy or supply side reform you
know that's the right toolkit that you
need to deploy bringing inflation down
and we just need to continue to stick to
the course and that's not easy that
involves difficult decisions but those
are the right long-term decisions for
the country because if we don't do that
inflation will just get worse and last
for longer and that doesn't help anybody
you've mentioned forecasts and the bank
of England the chair of court has
actually written to the treasury
committee to say that they're going to
do a root and Branch review of their
inflation forecasting models because
they have been wrong so what percentage
would you put on achieving your goals I
don't I don't have one for you I'm
working 100 to deliver it and we will
keep doing that that's all I can do is
just keep throwing everything at it and
as I said the broad mix of policy levers
we have of the monetary policy which is
independent government fiscal policy
which is in our control and supply side
reform
um those are the two leaders that we
have that we will make sure that we use
fully and I think everyone can see that
this is incredibly important and it's
important that we tackle it because
that's ultimately what is making people
poorer it's eating into the money in
their pockets and that's why they're
defeating inflation is such a central
premise and blank of our economic
Factory
do you accept that there's a higher
probability as of today that you will
miss that Target than there was at the
beginning I think there's a range of
forecasts but I don't spend my time on
that I can't control what I can control
is what we're doing and what I can tell
you is we remain committed to Bringing
inflation down and using all the tools
that our disposal to keep working to
bring inflation down right that's what I
should focus on and you know that's what
the government is going to continue to
do and given that the bank of England
have accepted they need to look again at
their inflation models
do you have confidence in the approach
that they're taking to bring inflation
down yes of course I'd support the bank
of England I mean they're modeling is a
is a matter for them and it's right that
you know they're having that dialogue
and and evaluating everything that they
do but of course I support the bank of
England the track the track record of
the independent Central Bank over the
bonds 20 25 years at keeping inflation
to Target has has been very strong I
don't think anyone thinks we should
return to a world where the government
is setting interest rates uh so I think
it is right that they're set
independently again it's not easy that
we bring there are no decisions are easy
when it comes to Bringing inflation down
but we have to do the things that arrive
for the long-term benefit of the country
you're confident that the tools that
they're using are the right one because
obviously they keep raising Bank grades
and that's affecting mortgage payers in
particular and actually a small cohort
of mortgage payers who are either on a
variable or whose fixed rates are coming
to an end it's a really small subset of
the population that are having to do the
heavy lifting in terms of reducing
demand through this monetary policy tool
is there nothing that could be done that
might sort of widen the the fiscal pain
as it were that would make it less of a
problem that the bank of England could
only sold through raising rates much
more sharply than they had anticipated
so again it wouldn't be right for me to
comment on monetary policy but there are
lots of different transmission
mechanisms for how monetary policy feeds
into the real economy obviously mortgage
rates are one but there are other ways
as well you're right about the
transmission mechanism being perhaps
slower when it comes to mortgages than
it has been in the past because of the
hundreds of people to have at least
short-term fixed rate mortgages now but
that's something that the bank take into
account in their modeling but so the
mortgage aspect of it is just one of the
many transmission mechanisms of the
monetary policy what else can we do well
that's what I talked earlier about
fiscal policy and supply side reform so
fiscal policy is making sure that our
borrowing is responsible our approach to
public sector pay is responsible if we
get those things wrong that makes the
inflation situation worse and with
supply side reform it's about making
sure that we are increasing the supply
of areas of the economy where you know
we are short as fundamentally leading to
some of the inflationary pressures so
whether that's in energy labor markets
or elsewhere I think we should Target
our policy there and look of course I
acknowledge the um the difficulty that
Rising interest rates pose for mortgage
holders I mean I just uh
yeah and the transmission mechanism of
them being people by the Banks do you
endorse the campaign that the treasury
committee's had on that look at the
chancellor I endorse what the chancellor
said was the issue needs to be resolved
I know he's met recently with the sca
and they've agreed to deliver better
deals for Savers by driving competition
and increasing reporting which I think
they're doing in the next few weeks in
particular to make sure that Savers are
benefiting from higher interest rates um
so I fully support the sda's review and
indeed the new consumer Duty gives them
a stronger power to take action if
necessary and alongside that the charter
for mortgage holders provides support
and relief for mortgage holders that are
facing difficulty with repayments
allowing them to either stretch the term
of their mortgages or switch to
interest-only payments either or both of
those can save people hundreds of pounds
a month potentially on their mortgage
bill when it reprices but also they can
do that without any impact on their
credit rating and there is also the
support for mortgage interest scheme for
more vulnerable borrowers which has been
increased in generosity and
accessibility so those are the different
things thank you
Clive bets for Department of for the
housing and communities and leveling up
committee yeah
I'm sure we can all agree that there's a
real problem in this country both the
rising housing costs and the shortage of
housing which affects the whole country
but some families in particular and
therefore it is important that the
government achieves its Target of
building 300 000 new homes a year I
presume that is still the government's
Target within at the end of the year you
consulted on through planning policy of
abolishing uh local housing targets that
councils have to meet
so when you get back to the office and
get out your spreadsheets and you look
at the 300 000 targets at the bottom
which the nation has to hit
how can that be done if the government's
going to give up its influence over the
individual Targets in each local area
that are supposed to add up to that 300
000. well why what I would say is we had
a commitment to deliver a million homes
over the parliament which we're
continuing to make progress towards I
think in the last year that we have
numbers for ending uh 2022 something
like 230 000 additional homes were
delivered which in itself was the third
highest yearly rate I think in the last
three decades
um and indeed if you look at the last
few years all of them have been in some
of the highest rates we've seen for
decades I think that shows that the
government's policies are are delivering
and we're making progress to our overall
ambition of a million homes over the
Parliament and and with regard to the
planning reforms I think it's important
that the planning system you know also
has the confidence of local communities
and it's and and planning targets remain
there but they're a starting point as
opposed to something that's being
imposed on communities without reference
prime minister if you're losing control
of the individual figures that add over
to it the lichfield's the planning
consultancy have said that the the this
planning policy in consultation is going
to reduce house building to 150 000 a
year half the government's Target
already this year housing starts have
fallen by 12 from the figure was well
below the 300 000 to begin with that
that's not success is it well I think
what his success is as I said delivered
some of the highest years of new homing
new housing additions in three decades
over the last few years and so I think I
chose the approaches is working and what
we are doing as well is ensuring that we
support local communities to bring
housing on stream particularly on
Brownfield land where we're investing
to help remediate land and unlock are
you affecting thousands of local
communities of vetoed then over
achieving the 300 000. no no it's it's
like I said what we're doing is we are
reforming how the planning system works
so that we strengthen the neighborhood
plans which actually particularly
neighborhood plans have shown that they
can deliver the housing that people need
in their local areas and but they do so
in a way that has a consent of the
community which is important and it
means that locally the character of
local areas and the particular
circumstances in each local area whether
it's Greenbelt or something else are
taken into account in assessing what is
a reasonable amount of housing sure how
that's going to get us to 70 000 more
homes when you're taking away the
ability to influence targets I'm just
going through one of the point prime
minister
um many people because they can't afford
a home there's no social housing to rent
end up in the private rented sector
sometimes Choice often because that's
the only place them to go
since 2020 the local housing allowance
which helps the poorest families pay for
the rent and the private rented sector
has been frozen
yet at the same time rents in the
private rental sector have risen by 25
there's now only one in 20 homes that
are covered by the local housing
allowance how is it fair for government
policy to impact so severely on the
poorest families who no longer can pay
for the rent of most homes in the
private rental sector with the
allowances that are available to them
so look I can't remember precisely but I
think we increased the local housing
allowance a couple of years ago by a
very significant amount of Frozen since
2020 pounds yeah but it was it frozen at
a level that was significantly higher
than it was before whereas about a 600
pound uplift to from memory about a
million and a half
families with 25 rent increase they
can't pay for so and actually there's
the discretionary housing payments of a
few hundred million pounds that are
there to support people as well as on
top of on top of housing benefit and the
affordable homes program has delivered
thousands of new affordable homes for
rent and will continue and will continue
to do so but it's affordable homes are
80 of Market rents prime minister
they're not affordable to most people
are they on the lowest incomes I look
it's a question of how you're targeting
that support but I said the the
affordable homes program I think it's
over a 11 billion pounds over its period
it's significantly higher than the one
that it replaced it's supporting
thousands of new affordable homes for
rent together with housing benefit
discretionary housing payments um you
know all that support is there but even
Public Service workers that nurses
policemen of us can't afford affordable
rents in London can be 80 of Market
rents are just not within the remit of
many public service workers struggling
on their current levels of pay yes which
is why on the other side we've taken
huge steps to help people with their
energy bills which is saving them around
1 500 pounds
um over the past few months raising the
national living wage by record levels to
put more money in their pockets raising
the threshold of which people start
paying National Assurance all of those
things also put more money in people's
parking a lot of people will think
promise you you're not really on their
side well I think if you actually look
at typical you can look at the case
studies of families in different
circumstances and what you'll see is
because of the support we've put in
place it is actually disproportionately
benefiting the most vulnerable families
now that's happening in lots of
different ways developers support with
energy bills the cost of living payments
that are worth 900 pounds that are going
to several million of the most
vulnerable households in our society
this year whether it's a national living
wage increase or the tax changes all of
those add up to quite meaningful support
for families deliberately targeted on
the most vulnerable families moving on
Catherine mckinnell for the petitions
committee thank you um but it's not
working is it prime minister do you take
responsibility for the fact the UK has
the highest inflation in the G7 and the
lowest growth protect projections
so I think we've had this debate in in
the past and if you look at the growth
projections actually we're the fastest
growing country in the G7 very specific
question no I asked a very specific
question which is do you take
responsibility before of course of
course of course I took response into
the government but I think I just to
correct what you're saying I think it's
important as as actually do you dispute
those facts we have the highest
um inflation rate in the G7 and the
lowest well no I'm just asking if he
disputes the facts
we're not putting them in context
because it's important as the head of
the IMF themselves says because those
are the the numbers that you are quoting
uh the head of the IMF themselves said
at a press conference here in the UK
which I'm sure the honorable lady was
listening to as soon as he's quoting the
figures that is actually not right to
focus on one specific year when it comes
to growth forecast and actually if you
look at any period either the two years
before where we were the fastest growing
countries all the projections for the
years thereafter we are not the lowest
grade
what we asked about inflation which I
think is important work bearing in mind
I've got quite a few um questions I need
to ask you and I think it's important to
focus on the reality of the people
contacting Us in Parliament about the
realities they face
one in seven are cutting back or going
without food because of a lack of money
currently that's one in four in my
region of the Northeast what level of
food insecurity does the government
assess is acceptable in this country of
course you don't want anybody to live in
food but that's a reality so what's the
government doing about it minister to
answer I agree so why don't we let's say
let me explain the various things that
we are doing to help people with the
cost of living so the first and most
significant intervention is to support
people with their energy bills because
that is the number one cost increase
that they're facing that support is
worth 1500 pounds it's about half of the
typical family's Energy bill and it is
benefiting All Families up and down the
country I think the second thing is for
the most vulnerable family so the ones
that the lady is talking about the
several million of our most vulnerable
families They will receive direct cost
of living support through the welfare
system those payments 900 pounds for
someone uh who is in receipt of
Universal Credit additional payments for
pensioners or those who are disabled uh
then also we're making sure that those
on low incomes are benefiting the
national living wage has gone up by
record levels and then particularly well
that all the money that people are
receiving can be used for whatever they
deem is most important to them including
food but the cost of living payments
that are going to people can be spent on
food so I think that does help people
and then very specifically on on food
you know what have we done is extend the
holiday activity and food program that's
funded hundreds of millions of pounds of
year that provides not just food but
also activities to disadvantaged
children outside of term time we have
Healthy Start vouchers for expectant
pregnant or new moms that also helps and
of course the free schools meal program
is there so I think if you put all of
that together whilst I except of course
things are challenging there are a range
of different measures in place to help
people with the cost of living deliver
and specifically targeted on the most
vulnerable in our society
in terms of mortgages millions of
current really terrified about what's
going to happen with their mortgage as
it comes up for review and have been
ever since the disastrous mini budget
last year of trust and quartet do you
know the number of people that are due
to remortgage by the end of 2024.
I don't have those numbers to hand but
what I can do and what would probably be
helpful is to explain to all the people
that you're talking about who you said
are anxious about that what the support
what support is in place to help them so
a typical mortgage outstanding in the
country is about 140 000 pounds or about
17 or so years left if that mortgage was
to reprice now
um that it would go up from around
770 pounds 800 pounds up to about a
thousand that's a significant increase
of course it is so what can someone do
in that situation well if they extend
the term of their mortgage which they
can now do thanks to our mortgage
Charter by say 10 years that will reduce
the monthly payments basically back down
to where they are currently they could
switch to an interest only period for a
while that will again reduce the payment
by hundreds of pounds and so those are
just a couple of things that they can do
so those for those who are most
vulnerable then as I said the support
for mortgage interest scheme is there
through the welfare system that provides
support for people much more quickly
than it used to so those are the
practical examples of how someone in the
circumstances that you're describing can
access support that will actually ease
some of the burdens for them not make
them disappear for sure but considerably
ease them what about the 15
who are not taking part in the
government scheme there's about million
mortgage
London that borrowers affected
what is the government doing about that
is it really enough to say to the banks
be nice
no I said the vast majority of the
mortgage Market is covered and the
chancellor is continuing to have those
conversations with the uh with the 15
that are not but the vast majority are
covered and that's why as I've outlined
for someone on a typical mortgage that
support can potentially all those
easements can potentially help offset
hundreds of pounds on their monthly
mortgage costs when they come to to
reprice as well as the support that's
there through the welfare system and
again they can do that without any
impact on their credit rating and
because of the consumer Duty that
um the transfer is introduced with the
FCA anyone facing fear of repossession
will have a full 12 months before that
can happen and the banks have a duty to
to act fairly and responsibly so as I
said of course I know it's a worrying
time but there are very specific
practical steps that are in place to
help people
thank you and moving on to William ragg
on constitutional matters for the public
administration constitutional Affairs
committee um thank you sir berners and
good afternoon prime minister prime
minister I hear alarming reports of a
blob wandering down Whitehall thwarting
the Ambitions of ministers
um do you recognize that
characterization yeah
no
and so where do you think it comes from
that it doesn't come from me that my
general you know my general experience
has been in the the jobs I've had
whether it's starting out at mhclg or
I've spent much time uh with Clive but
also in particular at the treasury over
the last few years and now number 10
that I've always been supported by
incredibly hard-working and diligent
civil servants who responded to what I
needed and worked all hours day and
night to deliver what I wanted so so
some current and former ministers have a
short-lived they might have been one
night at the realm is described as
blomanomics do you think this this talk
is really an excuse for weak ministers
and perhaps some workable policies I
think ultimately the elected government
of the day is responsible for the
policies uh that it is putting forward
and you know I would expect and indeed
have found in my experience the Civil
Service to be responsive to implementing
them and of course that requires strong
leadership and direction from from
editors and grip over what's happening
and of course you know things may
sometimes feel harder to to work through
than you would like them to but as I
said in my personal experience I haven't
found that to be an issue and so with
you with your experience which I accept
entirely do you sometimes take those
struggling ministers to one side and
perhaps put a friendly arm around their
shoulder and perhaps try to inculcope
that sense of work effort I think look
everyone is I think everyone is working
very hard to deliver for the country out
with a elected and appointed ministers
and also the Civil Service that works
for them of course the last few years
have not been easy for anybody given all
the various challenges pandemic war and
Ukraine and that the demands that that's
put on the entire system
um but I think everyone remains
committed to delivering and I think I
would expect them all to work very hard
to do so so reports of relations between
the government and Civil Service being
at an all-time low or somewhat
exaggerated certainly from my
perspective and that's not conducive to
delivering for the country if indeed
they were to be that right that my my
view and has always been that I've been
very fortunate to be served by
absolutely brilliant civil servants who
have given me everything I've always
answered them and more at all hours of
the day I've been very fortunate and
grateful to them for that support I
continue to find that in my current job
and I have no reason to expect that to
change or and my general viewers but you
know their their job is to support
government to do it and we should do
that in a constructive attitude and
that's what I'd like to see and expect
to happen thank you just come on to Mata
stew of House of Lords appointments if I
may
could you just briefly explain what you
understand to be the conventions around
resignation honors and in particular the
nomination of new peers
so my understanding is that
the previous Prime Ministers are
entitled to resignation honors they
would go through the normal vetting
process I followed what I
understand and believe to be the
long-standing convention of forwarding
those names to the palace for clearance
after they have been through the vetting
process because without any active
involvement engagement or interference
in that process and so you you know
conducted your constitutional role in
time proprietically
uh yes as I said I had no active
involvement or engagement in that
process I received a list and forwarded
it on unaltered the list that came
haven't been vetted by the house of
those appointments commission absolutely
I think there's only one example in the
past have that not been the case is that
right
none of yourself as prime minister I'm
not familiar with that example well I
think the example is Lord Trotters and
the next day gave the party donation for
those Italian reload time I said I've uh
I've whatever list that I've received
that has been through the vetting
process I forwarded on without
interference uh or active involvement in
it thank you for clarifying that
um could I ask if you think there's any
circumstances under which a residential
honors list is not appropriate I said
look it's a long-standing convention
that's been adhere to by I think parties
of uh on both sides of the house and I
fulfilled what I believe to be my
constitutional role in following
convention and forwarding on a list that
I received that had been vetted for
approval without interfering and uh and
pining on it and that has generally been
the case with political honors more
broadly uh you know they're forwarded
without the person in charge necessarily
agreeing with political honors more
generally and that's how the system has
has fund may I ask if you're still
reviewing the former prime minister's
trusses list I said I that process is
ongoing it hasn't reached me yet it
hasn't reached yet that that's helpful
this is this is entirely how
professionals you understand from my
cleanness for a concerted victory at the
next general election so please don't
take this the wrong way but if the
eventuality was that you uh the
circumstances would you think it
appropriate yourself to issue a
resignation on this list it's not
something I'm focused on or
I think that I think that's a fairly
good answer thank you sir thank you Mr
Right Pete Wishard Scottish affairs
the prime minister is now almost 25
years since the Scotland Act established
the Scottish Parliament and I think it'd
be fair to say that relationships
between the two governments have never
been so poor characterized as they are
by mistrust suspicion and antagonism
what are you personally doing to try and
improve the situation
well I think it's important to try and
have a constructive relationship with uh
all the devolved governments in the
United Kingdom and clearly we're not
going to agree on everything but that
doesn't mean
I do think it's important which is why I
think when I first had this job I spoke
I think on the first day to the as it
was then first Minister not just of
Scotland but of Wales I was also the
first Prime Minister I think in over a
decade to attend the British Irish
Council that brought together the
leaders from across the United Kingdom
and the Republic of Ireland that was
born and received I met with first
ministers in my role and have done with
the new first Minister and continue to
try and find ways to work
collaboratively together for freeports
being a good example of that whilst
acknowledging with it's clearly not that
we're going to agree on everything but
it's good to have the double
very lengthy and important
we now have a situation for the UK would
routinely ignores Scottish Parliament
legislative consent motions UK can now
legislate and evolved areas the nuclear
option of a section 35 being used for
the first time the Scottish government
ministers are even being recommended for
saying brexit is bad for Scotland when
meeting foreign delegations do you think
this muscular unionism is actually
working for you no as I said I think
there are examples of the Scottish
government UK government working
together particularly to deliver things
like freeports um but you mentioned the
section 35 I think we've had that today
in the past it was clear that there were
concerns about the operation of that law
on UK wide and uk-wide competencies and
areas of competence and it was
reasonable in that sense for the
Scottish Secretary of State after taking
the significant legal advice to issue
the section 35 and other you said I I
know yes the first time it's been used
but it was always invisible it was
always envisaged that it might be used
including I think by the SMP at the time
so I don't think people can debate the
principle at being used because it was
something that was supported at the time
and again obviously it's subject to
Illegal proceeding now how much we can
say the Scottish government with respect
the Welsh labor government recently
criticized the UK government's
unilateral and destructive approach to
Demolition and it's actually seeking to
have the yukima judicially reviewed the
northern Irish Executives and sitting in
Scotland Wales feels that the democracy
is under real thing it's Evolution
broken uh well again
um on Wales I spoke to the first
Minister and I think the first day I got
this job
I've spent time I've met with him again
delivering freeports which are a good
example of uh Wells and Scott Wales and
the UK government working together and
with regard to Northern Ireland because
you you brought it up I think actually I
think anyone can say that I haven't been
heavily actively involved in trying to
restore the executive in Northern
Ireland I think I've visited Northern
Ireland almost
five or six times in my first few months
in in this job and I think I should
demonstrate my commitment to Northern
Ireland the people of Northern Ireland
and the Windsor framework represents I
think a very significant intervention
that removed one of the big barriers to
the executive being restored in order
you know the UK government's given
themselves the provisions of the single
Market to get a stronger position from
Scotland and Wales isn't it the main
problem that the UK government
represents English interests while at
the same time being the arbitrary and
referee for the whole of the United
Kingdom and you've never given yourself
the powers within the European Union
surely the four nations idea across the
UK just isn't working anymore no I think
actually look the Scottish government as
far as I can recall when I last looked
at this was probably the most powerful
devolved assembly anywhere in the world
if not one if not the certainly one of
government also delivered all the
recommendations in the uh after 2016.
those have all been delivered and I
think the UK government is right that it
looks after uk-wide interests now as I
say some sometimes those will conflict
and we've seen that with the section 35
on the gender recognition gender
recognition act there's a court process
to resolve that so we should let that
let that run from itself the legislation
no I think that's because
you have job no to
note to feature when it comes to
Devolution that you don't like no
actually I mean on DRS actually the
drinks industry raised concerns about
Scottish governments
differing on the rest of the plans for
the UK now it's because they had an
interaction with UK interests that the
UK government uh had was requested for
the ukim exclusion and actually I said
there was an exclusion given on on
narrow terms and the decision to the
decision to not proceed was a decision
that was made by the Scottish government
said to be in the English national
interests that
judged me in the key interest is that
how it works though when we get to where
we are with these efforts for Nations
surely all four nations should be equal
and out these issues are approached well
as I said the the operation of the
scheme had an impact on uk-wide uh
interests and that's why income
exclusion was saw granted on a narrow
basis which would allow the scheme to
proceed in a particular way it was a
decision I think of the Scottish
government ultimately not to proceed
with it yeah because you made it
possible that's that's not right
actually I think the chief executive of
circularity in Scotland was category I
think it was categorical that the scheme
remain viable uh on that basis and many
successful schemes uh run without glass
so I I it was a Scottish government
decided not to proceed and that's a
decision that you know they they can
explain
for the standards committee thank you um
the ministerial code says when
Parliament is in session the most
important announcements of government
policies should be made in the first
instance in Parliament so why did you
announce the NHS Workforce plan not in
Parliament but outside Parliament
I thought I've always tried to announce
what I can in Parliament I think my
track record and the speaker's always
said in the past that I particularly uh
uh have done that
um where that's not possible or if the
statement is made immediately there
afterwards particularly last Friday I
think particularly whereas worth
considering that this is not just the
government's plan it's also the NHS you
could have announced it in Parliament on
Monday couldn't you oh well I I said
this is not just the government it
involved also the NHS because it was Mr
chess's long-term Workforce plan the
government was pleased to support it and
proud to support it and a compound that
will do something come off a special for
for the NHS in this 75th year the
speaker said yesterday the prime
minister is a member of parliament he is
answerable to the members of parliament
from all political parties I have to say
that his behavior was not acceptable he
may be the Prime Minister but the
members of parliament should hear first
have you apologized to the house yet as
I said I I've continued to be in
Parliament to answer members questions
on a range of issues making statements
on a range of topics and we'll continue
to do so but you're not coming to prime
minister's questions tomorrow are you
all next week uh yes because I am
attending the 75th anniversary
celebration for the energy you started
when that should be so you could have
happened tomorrow evening or tomorrow
morning uh no again that's not right I
did not decide uh when that was uh and
and quite frankly even if it was on a
different day also because his majesty
is in Scotland on Wednesday it might
have been reasonable for me to be there
as well and with regard to the week
afterwards I'm also at the NATO Summit
the reminder spoon of prime minister
suggesting that I shouldn't attend the
NATO Summit on behalf of the United
Kingdom as previous prime minister
reminders when the Prime Minister last
missed two prime minister's questions in
a row uh as I said I I I I don't know
but yeah as I said I'm well I don't know
it's important is the honorable
gentleman suggesting that I I don't
attend the NATO Summit which I'm not in
control of the dates of no I'm
suggesting that you should be attending
prime minister's questions and
um
and you should have made the statement
to the House of Commons because your own
ministerial code says that that's what
you should do so your view is so you
didn't your view is that it should not
be attending the NHS celebration or the
king's coronation celebration in
Scotland or indeed the NATO Summit
that's a perfectly reasonable point of
view but Parliament
you didn't turn up for the Owen Paterson
votes at all that's right isn't it
uh I I can't recall you didn't turn up
for the Boris Johnson
um vote at all did you no I was a a
charity dinner for Jewish care I think
that's some cutting it fine I would
argue since um other members of
parliament who were at the same dinner
with you and left after you did manage
to get back for the vote I think with
greatest respect I think their role and
my role at the dinner probably slightly
you chose not to be there didn't you
that's that's right two rule breaking
moments you chose not to be in
Parliament but yesterday you were bind
on the rules of cricket take us through
that uh I I chose to fulfill my
obligation to an incredible charity for
whom that is one of their significant
fundraising moments of the year at my
presence there was something that they
had asked for and actually me being
there and being able to thank their
volunteers okay and donors was something
that they appreciated others were there
where streeting was there as well he
managed to get back again with the
greatest respect I think his role in my
role at that dinner were probably
slightly different and okay I'm very
happy to talk about the rules of cricket
as you as you mentioned yeah but not
about rule breaking in Parliament
the Privileges committee
committee so the Privileges committee
has accused seven MPS of trying to
undermine and impugn its work the leader
of the house has condemned this do you
think that they should apologize to the
house I haven't actually gone through
the report yet so
you haven't read the report uh no I
haven't been through the report yet in
detail I've seen it being reported and
I've been very clear in the past that
you asked that Goldsmith to apologize
yes because so you have read it
sufficiently to note that Zach Goldsmith
should apologize yes I've read the
findings report I haven't read the
report from cover to cover no but I have
three pages long right but I've seen it
you know that Zach Goldsmith ought to
apologize but you haven't got an opinion
about whether the others because there's
a difference between Zach golfer's role
as a minister and I think that wasn't
consistent with him being a minister yes
oh so you have read the report
that I I have not read the every page of
the report I'm sorry which are you
talking about which reports sorry there
are two reports the report that we're
considering next week the one in which
it says that the the committee thinks
that the seven members of parliament all
of your political party were seeking to
impune and undermine the committee
report let me ask you something else you
have to authorize
um all foreign travel by trade and boys
and other parliamentarians and
parliamentary private secretaries in the
last year that's cost 264 192 pounds why
won't you publish the details of who
that's being spent on
it's not something I'm familiar with the
details of past practice on that but
I'll happily look into it okay different
question
um do you think UK businesses should
still be trading in Russia at all
I think UK businesses should be
following all the sanctions legislation
that we've been put in place do you
think they should be trading in Russia
at all a year after the second invasion
that there may be particular
circumstances in which some businesses
are in the process of either divesting
or where it's considered that it would
actually be
detrimental to our interests or hand
over assets for the Russians but as that
the job of business is to comply with
the laws that we set so man track man
track which owns unitrack fze sold new
diggers to Russia in April of this year
and you took five million pounds from
its owner is that right I said last
question I'm not familiar with a
specific company
um fill it down environmentally
committee
last time we met at this committee prime
minister you were very keen to pay
tribute to the leadership role of the UK
on climate and nature issues and you
particularly singled out Lord Goldsmith
for his role in delivering the
biodiversity deal in Montreal
are you still as proud of UK leadership
on climate and nature and view of Lord
Goldsmith's remarks and his resignation
letter last week yes I I'm uh I said I'm
grateful to him for the work that he did
which helped contribute to that role but
as I said we should be very proud of our
leadership role on tackling climate
change but also putting nature at the
heart of how we do so
so the ambition for Net Zero remains but
delivery over the past year and under
your Prime ministership has slowed and
the evidence for that is the client
committee on climate change report last
week in which Lord demon said in his uh
his finale to his forward to that annual
report that our confidence in achieving
the UK's 2030 Target of the fifth and
sixth carbon budgets has markedly
declined from last year through lack of
apparent delivery by officials taking
the signal that this has not been at
your priorities prime minister I think I
disagree with what with uh what that
Goldsmith said I think our record is yes
another just go more broadly our record
on this and I mean the facts are that
we've decarbonized faster than any other
G7 country like those those are the
facts that you know the facts are that
when we were presidents of cop we
insured a very successful cop that had a
clear trajectory to 1.5 made sure that
we increase the number of countries that
had binding Targets on Net Zero with
protected landbag relation Forest coal
financing there's a range of things that
we have led on and with regard to the
carbon budget again the facts are that
we have overachieved on every single one
of our carbon budgets to date we are on
track to have met the third that's what
the latest statistics show and I think
clearly for climate change said that
their confidence in the UK meeting the
fourth carbon budget has actually
slightly increased in the last year look
with regard to you know 20 33 then 2037
which is when some of these future
carbon budgets are
um of course we've already set out that
some of those policies will evolve over
time it's hard to predict right now with
certainty the exact shape of the UK
economy in 2037 but we've done a better
job of this than anybody else we have
the most ambitious targets compared to
anybody else so I felt nothing but proud
and confident in our record
do you expect the British government to
respond to both the U.S and the EU
significant interventions that have
happened this year
before the cop 28 meeting in November
sorry Phillip so we've had the inflation
reduction oh right so significant
measures I think look it's it's right
that other places are catching up with
us
right I mean that's the reality of it we
have decarbonized faster than any of
those other blocks so other countries
are having to catch up which is a good
thing which we welcome right that will
help combat climate change
um and I'm glad that they're doing so
and we we do this in a completely
different way historically we've done it
through things like contracts are
different and other things which have
brought tens of billions of pounds of
investment into this sector and if you
look at that over time and you actually
compare as a percentage of GDP what
we've done what the US have done we've
consistently out invested and we'll
continue to do so
um that's it's just that people do it in
different ways and I think you need to
compare on an apples to Apple's basis
and again one of the ways in which in
our contracts are different structure is
now being copied all around the world
and that is a different way to bring
investment into the green transition but
also one of the r d side we've protected
our r d budget it's growing that's
ultimately how we can also contribute
because if we can develop the
technologies that will help us deal with
these things and then commercialize them
that will do enormous good for the world
and that's something that plays to our
strengths as a country so looking
forward to cop28 do you plan to
prioritize UK leadership and if so how
are you going to demonstrate that yes I
mean again I've attended Copper's
Chancellor and we had a very successful
Finance day I think it was widely seen
to be the most successful Finance day
that cop had ever had and the centrality
of that made sure that we would be the
first Net Zero financial center and all
the things around tcfd disclosures and
other things which we've pioneered
that's what I did as Chancellor attended
last year we talked about nature in
particular last year and that carried on
at Montreal and we will continue to do
that this year as well and I think part
of the focus this year will be on
attracting private Capital to help with
the transition and that's something
given our strength and financial
services is an area where I think we can
obviously play a leading role in
thank you and moving on to Robin Walker
education committee thanks man
um you've referred prime minister to
education as the closest thing to a
silver bullet that we have you also said
at pmqs recently that children missing
school is a tragedy so how concerned are
you with the latest figures that show
that 24.2 percent of pupils were
persistently absent in the Autumn term
almost double the rate the previous year
look I think the first thing is I'm you
know it's welcomed at the number of
pupils who are persistently absent in
school fell by you know I think over 300
000 spring term
2022 to the year before but you're right
that persistent absence is a real
Challenge and the tools for responding
to it resolving it don't just lie with
department for Education as well and so
you know one of the things we're doing
is rolling out attendance hubs across
around 600 different primary and
secondary schools and to spread best
practice that will reach a big bad
quarter of a million children and the
work they do includes activities like
automatic text messages using data to
analyze proactively who might be at risk
those types of things and there's some
other things I can talk to but look it's
a real Challenge and it's why that we
focus on it in terms of addressing this
challenge one solution which the
government previously drafted
legislation for was a status register
for children not in school that's been
supported by the children's commissioner
of the select committee the opposition
front bench I think in pmqs recently um
and and it's something we have
legislation before the house from my
colleague on the committee flick
Drummond to address that is that
something that you feel the government
could Embrace and the liver
look we remain committed to introducing
the statutory local Authority register
for children as well as actually a duty
for local authorities to provide support
to home educating families you know we
will look to legislate at a suitable
opportunity
um to do so but obviously again without
preempting forward session legislation
since we last met you've the chancellor
has made very welcome announcements in
terms of child care and stepping up the
activity of the government in that
respect providing support to parents of
under three-year-olds that will mean a
shift from the government subsidizing
about 50 of the child care Market to
around 80 percent do you recognize that
that's an additional burden of
responsibility on ministers in the
government to make sure it is adequately
funded so that settings can keep going
yes just the first thing to say is that
a member of my family has a financial
interest in a child care company but as
well as the expansion that the child the
chancellor announced in the provision
extending the age entitlement
significant funding was put in today to
the deal with the existing entitlement
to meet inflationary pressures it was
around 200 million in this year paid
from this September and then a rising to
just shy of 300 million
um for the future year with further
uplifts to come what does that mean it
means a 30 percent increase in the
two-year-old rate which will take it to
around eight pounds an hour but also an
inflationary increase to the other rates
as well and and some of those rates I
think have been welcomed in theory by
some of the practitioners we spoke to
but there is a question mark over
whether they will actually receive them
given some of the Machinery of local
government through which the the rates
have to pass
um will you be encouraging ministers to
ensure that they do receive the the rate
at all close to the National rate that's
been advertised yes I mean the rates
were chosen in response to surveys with
I think thousands of nurseries to
understand that cost different cost
structure for provision they're adjusted
in local areas to account for local
differences and I I will I will go back
and make sure that the money is Flowing
as it is intended to but it has been
certainly been announced and just just
last year on this area one of the great
benefits of Early Education is early
identification of need in terms of scent
picking up issues early on being able to
address them early on allows children to
engage with their education in
mainstream schools who might otherwise
end up in much more expensive and more
limiting specialist placements
um however our committees heard that
only 18 of local authorities feel they
have enough provision for disabled
children in the early years is there
anything specific that you think should
be done to address that as part of the
wider efforts the government intend I'd
say The Descendant alternative provision
Improvement plan that we published in
March I think of this year and just sets
out the government's mission for sending
alternative provision and making sure
that it can fulfill and we can
collectively fulfill children's
potential and have trust of parents in
the system and financial sustainability
and alongside that we're increasing the
high needs funding by about 10 billion
pounds for this financial year which is
10 increase over last year's funding so
you know that should help
and moving further up the school system
there's been a lot of concern about
transparency on schools teaching of rshe
materials and uh how do you strike the
right balance between reassuring parents
and making sure that they can't have
access to these materials and making
sure that children do have access to the
curriculum that conservative government
introduced
yeah like look my personal view is it's
it's vital that what children are taught
in rshe is age-appropriate and factual I
was concerned by reports that wasn't the
case as was the education secretary
that's why we've brought forward a
review of the rhsc statutory guidance
we've assembled an expert independent
panel
um who are drawing on different
backgrounds health education equalities
children development safeguarding and to
help inform our work you know that work
should their work should conclude in
September and their recommendations will
perform a will help us form a public
consultation for later in the Autumn and
so that that's our approach to that with
regard to materials for parents although
we've been very clear you know parents
should be able to see all resources and
I don't think ministers have repeatedly
stated from the dispatch box that
parents should be able to see I think
courts have ruled otherwise if if there
is a legal issue here would legislation
be a possibility to address it I said
we're working through that as we speak
but our our general view is the
copyright law does not prevent a parent
from viewing external resources and
we've written to schools to clarify our
expectations but is that we that's you
know the review and the guidance will
will work through that particular issue
but our current position is a copyright
law shouldn't prohibit that from
happening great uh thank you and finally
Steve Bryan from the Health and Social
care committee thank you chair prime
minister well done well done on uh
getting the NHS long-term Workforce plan
out it's a it's a serious piece of work
and it's a big moment and and what
undertaking The Long View because you
know clearly a 15-year plan
um outlives even the next Parliament
when you're prime minister can ask you
about medical school training places it
says in the plan that the First new
medical school places will be available
from September 25. now presumably that's
about the the public expenditure cycle
we've heard from colleagues in medical
schools who are in a position now to
make offers for September 20 24 to
domestic students who want to be doctors
in in England
if they were funded places available now
the ucas deadline for September next
year is the 15th of October this year is
there a reason why we're kicking in in
September 25. uh well it's it's not just
the medical training places my
understanding of it is we need to make
sure that the pipeline can also deal
with the other training that people will
need not just in the medical schools and
the system needs to be able to deliver
that at the same time but also as one of
the things we talked about is we're
looking at the medical school training
itself and looking at whether there are
ways to improve the efficiency and
streamline that process and we want to
make sure we do that work because if
there's a way to fund medical school
training places that are done in a more
efficient or effective way we'd like to
do that so that is that work needs to
happen as well and I think that will
take some time because that will
obviously involve the medical Regulators
to look at potential different ways of
training students and making sure that
they're okay with it if we can do the
training in a slightly shorter period of
time whilst obviously maintaining the
quality that would be beneficial and if
we want the incremental funding into
that ideally so we need time for that
process to play out there's a lot of
announcements in the plan I mean I think
you could have filled your number 10
grid for for many many weeks hence with
the number of things that are in here
one of which was talking about with
respect to training dentists a tie-in
period to encourage dentists to spend a
minimum minimum proportion of their time
delivering NHS care in the Years
following graduation
could you tell us how long that could
potentially be in your mind and was that
discussed in political circles for
doctors more widely yeah I think I I
address this at the the press conference
it um
I think people have raised concerns both
on the medical side and the Dentistry
side the work was done on the medical
side and I think I said that I haven't
got the numbers to ham but I think
around 95-ish percent uh of people who
had done medical training off a certain
period of time were still an NHS
practice so the issue was I think far
less widespread than
most people assumed it to be which is
why it didn't seem like right now it was
necessary
um the issue on Dentistry was more
pervasive where I think I said I'd have
it to hand but around I think only
two-thirds of those who had trained at
some point later were doing NHS book
providing NHS Services that's obviously
a far more significant issue and that's
after the receipt of hundreds of
thousand pounds of taxpayer support
during training so it did seem
reasonable to explore options for a tie
there but as I said no conclusions but
that seems to be something that is worth
exploring for Dentistry at this stage
the issue in medicine seems to be less
pervasive than so just just sticking
briefly with teeth because you'll know
there's huge concern among our
constituents about access financial
industry there is talk to the Dentistry
plan from the Department
um presuming that you wanted to get the
workforce plan out first could you give
any update to constituencies as to when
they might that I you know I don't have
an update but I can't tell you that
we're still getting on and there's more
money that's been put into Dentistry
particularly there's been some reform
and changes to the existing Dentistry
contract and high performing practices
are able to provide I think about 10
more activity which should also help and
the number of dentists higher now than
it was before and the last set of
numbers that I've seen but not
necessarily doing NHS work of course
that's the challenge sorry not
necessarily doing NHS work but I said
that that's why the workforce plan not
only trains more dentists but also as
exploring the Thai all right the reforms
of the contract should hopefully
increase NHS just finally the plan says
on page 13 Rising demographic pressures
uh and changing burden of disease or
increasing demand for NHS Services well
yeah and some I mean demand continues to
outstrip supply with an aging population
and I just wonder where are you on the
prevention agenda prime minister because
it has to be better than cure you know
when you see that we've kicked the buy
one get one free regulations down the
line the advertising restrictions for
food high fat salt sugar that's been
pushed down the line
where are you personally on the
prevention of ill health no of course
prevention is always better than uh
better than a cure I think it's it's
worth being cognizant of the particular
challenges with inflation and the cost
of living that we face at the moment and
I think that's it's reasonable to course
correct for for that but more generally
you can see what calorie labeling on
menus for example is a good example of
that and then if you look at the
provision most recently of anti-obesity
medicines uh that should that should
help and because we know there's a link
there between other conditions like
heart disease and diabetes but then also
uh on smoking where the switch to stop
program again is trying to to act
proactively and I think quite
innovatively in the achieve medical
office here would be able to talk to you
about it better than I can but there's
such persuasive evidence that that
program of the schemes that we've done
on a smaller scale if you can help
people switch away from smoking to using
Vapes this is not disposable children
which is obviously concerning and I've
spoken about in the past but for
existing adult smokers to switch
um there are clear public health
benefits of that before bigger problems
and come down the line so those are some
examples of the things we're doing in
the prevention space and thank you for
getting the plan out check uh thank you
um well we've done it extremely well and
we're going to finish it even a little
early partly because I focus on my own
questions to a large extent but could I
just ask to Chris bright who has
volunteered to correct the record
many apologies I said that was treating
had voted on the 19th of June and I was
wrong so I just want to put the record
straight apologies to the committee
thank you very much indeed prime
minister thank you for your attendance
today maybe we can have an extra 10
minutes or so next time but um I'm most
grateful to you for attending thank you
very much order order
hey
the proceeding has ended